pilot to Bombardier it's Friday morning
the 21st [__] slinging dick and
giving our firecrackers this is how you
start your morning understand me are you
kidding me or what uncle Joey here
slinging dick and giving up [__]
dreams on the Friday morning ready to
[__] rock you understand me I got a
meeting at 10:00 I got a meeting at
12:00 I got a meeting at 2:00 I gotta
take my daughter the [__] gymnastics
at 4:00 and then we had a little family
tell her tonight and that's it my
weekend is [__] over but I think I
touched him with my [__] church
family to make sure what the [__] is
crackalacking for starters happy
birthday to my little brother Michael
Klein without you you know I'm saying
you're the [__] goods one by one
podcast give it a listen
number two Ari Shaffir isn't [__]
Washington waiting for you [__]
and number three
sharpen your dick it's Friday
[__] who needs the condom going
that beep give me a little rash around
your mouth [__] who gives a [__]
you're special
anyway we got the weed that killed
[__] everybody till you understand we
got the superglue take a look at this
[__] thing right here 26 all right I'm
gonna burn a little bit of that we got a
couple different reads two experiments
from clay cause we're not [__] around
understand I'm not gonna bother you at
7:00 in the [__] morning you know who
bothers just sell in the morning to come
over to join your uncle Joey that's the
type of [__] I am knocking on
your door Bluebird of happiness but with
the best [__] weed you get your hands
on you understand me and we don't give a
[__] I got a big day but listen this is
how I handle the whole [__] deal
stoned to the [__] gills you'd only
say no a a meetings for me
there's the weed that makes you go
definition I'm hearing [__] little
heart attack noises as we speak
look at this hatch here this is the
banana OG right there oh look at this
[__] a monster and that clueless
this is what [__] Ilan must know when
he thought he was only gonna [__]
move that [__] knucklehead you know
take people to the moon the astronauts
what are you [__] crazy or what I am
paying you [__] I got a little
moon here every day by myself I smoked
some of this [__] I see meteors I see
[__] Martians I see Isis I see
everybody already I don't need to know
how to get on a [__] rocket ship with
nobody understand me don't forget West
Palm Beach the 11th through the 13th
don't tell me I didn't know this is my
only appearance to Florida that's a long
[__] way away from coach I thought
long triple-eight like 19 edibles on
xanax and [__] sit next to wipe out
of mine just in case I need a little
blast aah anyway Joey which would the
[__] have beaten today
there's banana OG is a [__] good you
understand me I love it
hooking up with you [__] on a
Friday get your weekend off elusive
we're gonna get this [__] party
started right why jungle jatin jit uncle
G I'm [__] stutter on my [__]
Lybrand 187 cuz you uncle joey's he'll
that's why I let you know that you could
make it happen so today's your day
whether you gettin paid
or you're not getting paid you're
getting paid somebody's getting hit in
the head with a [__] that new Chuck
you understand me
always last time you hit a [__]
with a new Chuck nobody shows up in new
Chuck's no more you show up in a [__]
Walmart on a new Chuck nothing's gonna
happen everybody's like what the [__]
happened they have none you smoke some
weed but uncle Joey anyway let's do this
lap one let's do a couple more what the
[__] we think you're dealing with joy
bananas it's [__] Friday if you're
not gonna smoke we go back to [__]
hanging out with your buddies and
hitting a vapor pen and drinking
Starbucks coffee Oh ain't enjoy this
Mochaccino you might as well cook up and
suck sperm and get some hummus out of
somebody's dick visits the same [__]
flavor I'm over here schmuck and morphed
you understand you know one month means
an Italian debt
oh jesus [__] christ and we're saving
this for last but it's [__] source
are you kidding me this is [__]
box box dude how are you today I hope
you're good look at me I'm like a
[__] puppet egg anyway I'm gonna
[__] smile I forgot I'd never forget
about you [__] I'm busy guys
I'm trying to pull it together I'm a dad
I'm a man of many [__] hats but you
know what I still got time man with the
church family because remember as we
saying cube or you think I might have a
ping Howie
tell me seeking the home ain't come
corner you make towel on my boy girl I
might but get it though you well how
come buthow sorry evil I said PC Mike I
have it called Elim I said it aka or
Baba hire poeple that I see in Chino
anyway I smoked a little bit more this
and then we got into the world
I let [__] know it's gonna be
alright cuz half these people watch the
news they're walking around all
petrifies gonna be our head who gives a
[__] I'm saying you get hit in the head
with a missile just make sure you got a
joint that's all I don't give a [__]
you're up there you gotta make it sweet
like pink floor you gotta be able like
that the easy meat with your eyes closed
you follow me that's the whole secret of
these mother
they don't know that you know they don't
know that you know I'm sayin I love
these people real recognizes real huh
multi is a bunch of [__] hardly
[__] homos both suck my dick and call
me shorty I was born in 1940 you follow
me uncle Joey knows we know you follow
me
tremendous the long feels good
I'm ready a rock on bro I'm gonna do
some strength training today at 2
o'clock and that's it and that's that I
just wanna touch base with you
[__]
let you know thank you very much
listening to the podcast thank you for
supporting the church you know we try we
ain't no [__] Good Morning America
but with just two fat [__] trying
that's all that matters
we always [__] at em on their way as
they consistency that's all that matters
you you put the rest together
[__] uncle Johnny ain't [__]
around this weekend next weekend Boston
sold out oh he can son sold out next
time I plan ahead [__] and west
palm I'm coming in [__] heavy I kept
up until the [__] 11th to the 13th
that's all I know right now that's all
we think I know Joe D is too late and
wet whatever [__] me anyway I love you
[__] with all my heart and have
a great weekend keep the eyes open you
know saying watch your family love your
family
and don't forget to smoke some dope I
love your mother [__] see you Monday
early tip-top Magoo